λλος να σας εμπισστε να μας εμπιστευτούν πέραν τρις ευρωπαϊκής και τις παγκός μιες όμως
πονδίας πουείναι ιάμεση μας ετσιδασμευθί υπάρχει και μια ετεράστιαδέμεση προς την κυβέρνηση ο ολόκληρη είναι
πολύ σημαντικών αυτόν που λέω υπάρει μια νιώθουμε τρσια τερά στη ανευθύνη στους στους όμως
μας θέλουμε να βγάλουμε όλου σας προπρόσωπος στον κόσμο και πλώ στον αθλστον πασκετσιών κόσμο
γιατί περιμένουν όχι να δούν τις εκαπεντεμέρες τις διοργάνσης περιμένουν πια θα είναι συμπεριφορά μας
την αμέσως επόμενη μέρα διόι θησέ όταθα αι μεταλευτούμε τα όσα πήραμε αυτό το διάσταθα
κεφαλο οποιήσουμε όλα αυτά τα φέλει διότι όταν κλείσουν τα φώτα όλοις αυτής τις λάμψεις
κλείσουν τα φότα και θα μείνουμε πάλει μόνι μας δηλαδή η όμως πόνι διαμπάσκετα θα
μίνει μόνι της θ φύγουν όλοι και η ι ευρωπαίοι και η φιλά θα μενουμε
μόνι μας στο κουτί μας πλέον πάλι να έχοντας όμως όλοι ν αυτή την εμπιρία
την τεχνογνωσία τα ωφέλει όλα αυτά τα όπλα όλα τα εργαλεία ταο οποία να θα
μας μας δοθήκαν θα πρέπει να κάψουμε κάτω και νανούμε πως και θαε το επόμενο
που θα καθα μνομε βήμα όχι κατανάγκι να κανείς μια μεκαλή διργάνωση ανλά πως θα
χρησιμο οποιήσεις όλα αυτά στο να μεγαλώσεις τη βάση του αθλήματος ώστε και εθνική θα
έχει και μέλο δηι να αυτόν που πα μπριν άρχισαν οι εφανίσεις που δεχνω ότι
δεν είμαι εθυι ευνθεωρώ ότι θα έχει μελών βλέποντας τη ζώντας στην καθημερινά και και
ιλικιακά αλλά και των τρόπο που τα παιδιά ανταποκρινοντά το μεγαλύτερο στίχημα τοωοποίον καιερδίζεται είναι
ότι βλέπουν στα μάτια αντιπάλου της οποίυς δε α ον ιρεύνταγκάν ότι θα μπορούσαν να
βέξουν να αυτόν τους σιχνή τους δύναάλλον κίνητο να άλλο να εράν αναθεωρώ όταν τελειώσουμε
με το καλόν και θα πανέύθουμε πίσω στις νόρμα οργανώσεις τις οποίες ως εππεδον να
ρούμε θα είμαστε θερό χώρα η οποία θα διεκδικούμε μπλέον πάρα πολλά πράγματα με την
εθυνική στο επίπεδον το που θα είμαστε θαλασερώτησ